bonjour aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
de la façon dont l'espace change nos
codes et ce depuis plus de 60 ans oui
seulement 60 ans en fait que l'homme va
dans l'espace c'est l'espace d'une vie à
peine il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
nés avant l'ère spatiale et qui n'ont
pas connu les satellites et pourtant
nous maintenant nous utilisons des
satellites dans notre quotidien sans
même nous en rendre compte
chaque jour nous utilisons des dizaines
de satellites mais il y à 60 ans il
n'était pas encore question de tout cela
est en fait l'ère spatiale elle a
commencé en 1957 elle a commencé en 1957
avec ça ça c'est ce pique nique le
premier satellite artificiel qui a été
lancé par l'homme et le 4 octobre 1957
dans l'urss spoutnik vous voyez c'est
une petite faire une petite sphère de 60
cm de diamètre 80 kg mais ce qu'est la
d'exceptionnel cette petite sphère cck
trentaine qui ont commencé et ce pendant
ces trois mois de vie à émettre des bips
bips en tournant autour de la terre et
tous les radioamateurs dans le monde ont
capté c'est bip bip et ont su que
désormais il y avait un espèce de comme
on l'a dit à l'époque d'oiseaux
métallique qui tournait autour de la
terre en continu mais la panique panique
aux états unis on était en pleine guerre
froide et ça signifiait que leurs
rivales l'urss était en mesure de lancer
des fusées
or qui diffusait dit missile
intercontinental parce qu'un missile une
fusée c'est la même technologie en
réalité est aussi ça signifiait que
l'urss avait la capacité de survoler
leur territoire librement de les
observer de les écouter donc inquiétudes
sur cette suprématie technologique de
l'urss
et puis ça va aller très vite quatre ans
plus tard rebelote mais cette fois ce
n'est pas un petit objet c'est pas une
sphère métallique on lance c'est un
homme et c'est le premier homme dans
l'espace youri gagarine voyez même même
jusque dans le journal de l'auvergne la
nouvelle est arrivée
ça a été l'événement incroyable en 1961
le premier homme dans l'espace alors oui
youri gagarine il a il a dû se faufiler
au sommet de la fusée y avait une petite
capsule
il fallait faire moins d'un mètre 70
pour pouvoir être cosmonautes à l'époque
tellement la capsule était étroite et il
a été propulsé par cette fusée à plus de
300 km d'altitude pour un vol qui a duré
un peu moins de deux heures il a fait
une orbite de terre complète et donc il
a été le premier humain à voir de ses
yeux la rotondité de la terre la terre
vue de l'espace mais aussi la nuit en
orbite avec la splendeur des étoiles
hors de l'atmosphère
et alors là vous imaginez les états unis
double panique parce que là maintenant
la suprématie elle est vraiment bien
installée et il se trouve qu'en avril 61
c'est un hasard de l'histoire
le président kennedy faisait face à une
crise dramatique à cuba et c'était le
l'épisode qu'on a appelé plus tard
l'épisode de la baie des cochons un
fiasco terrible pour les états unis et
au même moment donc ce lancement de
gagarine qui vraiment humilie les états
unis et on raconte que kennedy arpentait
les couloirs de la maison blanche en
disant qu'on apporte un homme qu'on
m'apporte un homme qui est une idée qui
est une idée pour battre les soviétiques
sur ce terrain sur lequel les américains
considéraient qu'il devait avoir le
leadership comme il l'avait eue sur
l'aviation
quelques dizaines d'années plus tôt et
donc effectivement kennedy
une semaine après le lancement de
gagarine envoie un mémo à son vice
président qui était en charge du spatial
et il lui dit trouvez moi une idée pour
battre les soviétiques et il dit est-ce
qu'on peut envoyer un homme sur la lune
et bien visiblement la réponse a été oui
puisque le 25 mai 1961
kennedy fait une conférence de presse et
il annonce au monde entier que oui
l'homme va marcher sur la lune avant la
fin de la décennie et que cet homme sera
américain est là c'est assez incroyable
parce que le pari va être tenu c'est à
dire que huit ans après le 20 juillet
malgré le fait que kennedy était
assassiné en 63 malgré le fait que la
guerre du vietnam depuis 1964 a pris de
l'ampleur que le ça coûte très très cher
au gouvernement américain cette guerre
c'est très compliqué politiquement et
bien malgré tout cela le 20 juillet 1969
neil armstrong pose le pied sur la lune
événement incroyable avec un
retentissement incroyable et là les
états unis ont gagné définitivement
alors là j'ai une petite anecdote à vous
raconter le premier homme à marcher sur
la lune seigner lé armstrong je crois
que tout le monde le sait mais le
deuxième homme ces buzz aldrin et moi
jeune ingénieur démarrant ma carrière
dans le spatial dans les années 90 j'ai
eu la chance d'être présenté à buzz
aldrin lors d'un congrès un congrès qui
s'occupait justement du futur de 2
qu'est ce qu'on fera dans l'espace après
la lune est-ce qu'on ira sur mars
on ira à coloniser l'espace et à
l'époque je ne me suis pas rendu compte
de de la personne que je rencontrais gt
oui je savais qu'ils s'étaient mais je
n'avais pas conscience de ce qu'il
représentait il ya seulement 12 hommes
qui ont marché sur la lune à ce jour
douze hommes entre 1969 et 72 et sur les
douze il n'en reste plus que quatre
vivant j'ai revu buzz aldrin y en a 1 an
et demi à washington dans un autre
congrès il est encore plein dans
toulouse
ce passionnant et il milite toujours
pour la continuation de l'aventuré
spatiale
mais il n'en reste que quatre et
j'espère qu'on retournera sur la lune
avant qu'ils ne soient tous mans mais en
fait je ne suis pas venu pour vous
parler de l'homme dans l'espace
je suis pas venu pour vous parler
d'apollon je suis venu pour vous parler
d'apollo 8
parce qu'avant d'imposer un homme sur la
lune
il ya eu une mission à noël 1968 où pour
la première fois des astronautes ont
quitté l'orbité terrestre
c'est à dire que c'est la première fois
que ces trois astronautes sont montés
dans un vaisseau qui les a emmenés hors
de la terre
loin de la terre vers un autre objet
spatial et là ça a été vraiment quelque
chose d'incroyable parce que ils sont
partis à quatre cent mille kilomètres de
la terre ils ont fait plusieurs orbite
lunaire ils ont vu la face cachée de la
lune qui par définition n'était pas
visible depuis la terre et surtout
qu'est ce qu'ils ont vu et bien ils ont
vu ça ils ont vu la terre vue de la lune
et la terre vue de la lune c'est quoi
c'est une petite boule bleue dans un
espace très sombre infini comme une
petite balle de golf qui ce qui flotte
dans cet espace noir est là cette photo
d'ailleurs a fait le tour du monde ils
ont pris conscience que la terre est
fragile la terre est unique
la terre est petit il n'y a pas de plan
b en fait et notre devoir c'est de la
préserver et on ne peut le faire que
tous ensemble c'est pas quelque chose
que un pays ou un continent peut faire
c'est un problème de l'humanité tout
entière
et de là on peut dire que l'espace a
créé le mouvement écologique
l'espace a créé l'écologie parce qu'il a
fait ce choc de compréhension ce choc de
code ce changement total de perception
sur la fragilité et l'unicité la terre
et depuis bien sûr
nous utilisons le spatial au quotidien
parce que non seulement le spatial nous
a permis de prendre conscience de cette
fragilité mais en plus il nous permet de
la mesure et c'est à dire que pour
pouvoir surveiller l'environnement pour
pouvoir mesurer les dégâts qu
éventuellement nous nous faisons en dur
et à notre planète il faut des outils
que seul l'espace que nous fournir des
outils globaux qui nous permettent de
faire des mesures régulières comparables
sur de longues années sur de longues
décennies les mesures qui permettent de
voir la terre toute entière
là vous avez une photo d'un satellite
météorologique ses trente-six mille
kilomètres d'altitude mais à environ 800
km 1000 km de la terre vous avez d une
série de satellites sentinelles qui
surveille au quotidien l'environnement
la déforestation la pollution
atmosphérique alors par exemple vous
avez ce genre de constatation savez que
nous avons eu un confinement l'année
dernière et que donc du jour au
lendemain tout s'est arrêté
les déplacements les avions les voitures
tout tout s'est arrêté là on peut voir
grâce à un satellite à quel point ça
réduit la pollution ça c'est la
pollution au dioxyde d'azoté alors sur
la sur la photo de gauche c'est la
france en mars 2019
la photo de droite mars 2020 vous voyez
à quel point en quelques jours de
confinement puisque le confinement
avaient démarré en réalité 15 mars 2020
et bien la pollution avait drastiquement
diminué sur les grandes agglomérations
donc c'est ça aussi que nous permet
l'espace est aussi plus récemment
vous vous souvenez de ce grand bateau au
container qui à bloquer le canal de suez
est bien là aussi on a pu suivre cette
crise depuis l'espace on a vu au départ
sur la photo de gauche les bateaux en
période normale qui attendent de pouvoir
s'engouffrer dans le canal de suez et
puis à droite vous avez les bateaux qui
s'accumulaient
attendant de pouvoir enfin passer et on
a pu voir aussi depuis l'espace très
clairement le bateau qui causait le
problème est qu'ils étaient en sable et
donc oui nous nous utilisons l'espace au
quotidien pour mesurer ses effets pour
pour surveiller suivre les catastrophes
et ce n'est qu'un exemple du changement
de code que nous a donné l'espace mais
je vais vous en donner trois autres qui
me paraissent importants pour que vous
mesuriez quel point l'espace compte dans
nos vies
premier exemple la navigation la
localisation alors les étudiants de
l'utc sont la génération qui a toujours
eu un gps ou un galileo puisque vous
savez que l'europe à un système analogue
qui est galileo et qui est même plus
précis que le gps mais moi je n'étais
d'une génération ou si on n'avait pas de
carte ou de plan risquait de se perdre
et pour ceux qui font de la voile ils
sont bien contents maintenant d'être
dans une ère où il ya des satellites
parce que là par exemple cette photo
c'est celle du sauvetage de escoffier
pendant le dernier vendée globe
sauvetage spectaculaire grâce à jean le
cam
mais pourquoi est-ce que ce sauvetage a
pu se faire parce que escoffier a
déclenché sa balise argos quand il a
chaviré et donc il a été localisable et
donc on a pu le sauver
et ça c'est aussi ça les systèmes de
navigation et de localisation
un autre effet un autre une autre
utilisation de ces systèmes de
navigation et de localisation
c'est la synchronisation et en
particulier la synchronisation des
transactions bancaires c'est à dire si
demain il ya plus de satellites de local
de localisation et navigation qui
fonctionne tout le système bancaire
mondial et bloquer les distributeurs de
biens ne fonctionne plus et c'est donc
vous voyez il ya même des utilisations
auquel on ne pensait pas mais qui sont
quand même importante dans notre vie
quotidienne
autre exemple la science la science et
la recherche
quand on veut comprendre la formation de
lutte système solaire et surtout
comprendre comment la vie est arrivé
dans notre système solaire on
s'intéresse aux comètes
pourquoi les comètes parce que les
comètes ce sont les vestiges du système
solaire originel ce sont les vestiges de
la nébuleuse qui a donné naissance à
notre système solaire et donc nos
scientifiques cherchent à comprendre la
composition des comètes et à vérifier si
elles sont bien à l'origine peut-être de
la vie sur terre
une comète c'est quoi c'est une grosse
boule de glace un peu poussiéreuse comme
on dit et bien l'agencé spatiale
européenne a monté une mission qui
permettait d'aller voir et comme elle et
je pense que vous vous en souvenez
c'était la mission rosetta fila et donc
c'est une sonde qui est parti en 2004 et
quitte arriver en 2014 sur une comète
c'est celle que l'on voit avec une forme
un peu bizarre en fait elle est composée
de deux objets qui sont agglomérés et
cette comète qu'on appelle toujours y
est bien rosetta a fait plus de 6
milliards de kilomètres de voyage en dix
ans pour l'atteindre et se mettre en
orbite autour de cette comète et même
faire déposer à sa surface
un petit un petit robot phil hay eh bien
on est encore en train de dépouiller les
résultats parce qu'on a
cette mission a duré longtemps en
réalité elle a duré plusieurs années et
on a des masses de résultats mais ce
qu'on sait d'ores et déjà c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'on a toujours
pensé l'eau terrestre ne vient pas des
comètes parce qu'on a pu comparer la
composition isotopique de l'hydrogène et
de l'eau sur la comète avec celle de la
terre et ont rendu compte que elles ne
sont absolument pas similaires donc
première surprise l'eau terrestre ne
vient pas du bombardement cométaire que
la terre a subi pendant sa jeunesse
quand elle était en train de se former
elle était chaude
elle était recouverte de l'océan et il y
avait des comètes qui ce qui se
fracassé sur la terre en permanence et
bien non clos ne venait pas d'eux c'est
commettre et vraisemblablement l'eau
venait des astéroïdes
en revanche et ça c'est bien
il y a bien sûr les comètes des acides
aminés du phosphore qui explique et se
vous savez les acides aminés le
phosphore sont des composants importants
de l'adn donc il est vraisemblable que
oui la vie sur terre vient en tout cas
en partie des comètes
autre leçon scientifique alors là c'est
un selphy de la fameuse rosetta avec la
comète derrière autres selphy autres le
fonds scientifique c'est mars
persévérance et ingénierie qui que vous
avez vu est la question la seu et passer
l'eau martienne
où est elle passée c'est tout parce
qu'en fin mars a été recouvert d'eau
liquide avec des océans des rivières qui
ont creusé des canyon où est passé cet
os que la terre risque de connaître ce
sort on ne sait pas mais ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il faut aller sur mars pour
comprendre et avoir la réponse à cette
question pourquoi est ce qu'il y à trois
milliards d'années
mars est devenu une planète aride et
pourquoi peut-être la vie qui existait
avant a disparu c'est des questions qui
nous interpellent aussi si on veut se
s'inquiéter de l'avenir de notre planète
et enfin un dernier point c'est que
l'espace c'est la coopération l'espace
vous apporter aussi ce changement de
code de la coopération mondiale
l'espace est née de la guerre froide et
de la rivalité entre états unis et vers
ss mais dès la chute du communisme
etats unis et russie ont regroupé leurs
infrastructures pour faire une station
la station spatiale internationale qui
est d'ailleurs le premier projet sur
lequel j'ai travaillé dans le spatial et
c'est cette station vers laquelle va
s'envoler thomas pesquet la semaine
prochaine il va en prendre le
commandement pendant six mois
cette station qui abrite six astronautes
en permanence au dessus de nos têtes à
400 km d'altitude et ce depuis 2000 donc
là c'est une coopération mondiale et la
rivalité entre chine et états unis
certainement je l'espère se résoudre à
dents aussi une coopération peut-être
sur une base lunaire peut-être sur une
mission vers mars
et oui thomas pesquet va partir mais
l'espace change les codes les codes de
l'espace change aussi parce que thomas
pesquet va partir avec space x et le
mouvement new space nous interpelle
ils nous obligent à changer la façon
dont nous faisons du spatial nous oblige
à penser en termes de baisses de coûts
d'accès à l'espace de lancement très
fréquente de constellation de satellites
pour donner de l'internet à tous à haut
débit tout partout dans le monde et ça
c'est bien parce que ça nous oblige à
réviser nos bottes de travail et je
pense que c'est une chance que nous
avons et je suis convaincu que avec ce
mouvement new space et avec l'évolution
qu'ils nous imposent et bien l'espace
continuera à changer nos codes
continuera à changer nos perceptions et
je pense d'ailleurs que un jour viendra
où
le problème des ressources terrestres
qui sont en quantité limitée sera résolu
grâce au spatial
alors moi je pense que il ya plein de
choses à faire dans l'espace on peut
être astronaute on peut être ingénieur
si vous voulez être astronaute l' agence
spatiale européenne recrutent
vous avez jusqu'au 28 mai pour
candidater mais quoi qu'il en soit et ça
j'en suis convaincu et j'espère vous en
avoir convaincu les clés du futur de la
terre se trouve dans l'espace
merci